Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata
Visto il successo in passato della Posta
del Cuore ho pensato di riadattare
questo tema e di ampliarlo in un certo
senso, cercando di renderlo universale
Per la prima volta su questo canale
lanciamo "La Posta di Sonia"
Ho pensato di invitare un ospite che meglio di
chiunque altro potrebbe portare avanti
questo messaggio e potrebbe veramente in
un certo senso ricalcare quelli che sono
i passi che stiamo cercando di seguire,
ossia Sonia stessa. Grazie eccomi. Ciao
Benvenuta! Grazie Guglielmo. Grazie di cuore per aver
accettato questo invito. Grazie a voi per l'invito
Vi faccio solamente un cappello introduttivo
Se siete laziali e avete mai messo piede
nel Lazio da bambini, sapete esattamente
...chi sono...
di chi stiamo parlando e state
fangirlando come me. Se non lo sapete
sappiate che tutti quanti i cartoni che
avete visto, tutti quanti i programmi per
bambini che avete visto, sono nati grazie
a lei, è partito tutto da lei. Cioè Ken il
guerriero...lei
Allora tu sei stata secondo me la
mamma, l'amica, la baby sitter, la zia di
tantissimi bambini ma oggi arrivano gli
adulti. Un altro mondo. Vediamo un pochino
che cosa ci chiedono...zia Sonia dai...esatto...nonna Sonia mi sembra un po' esagerato. Nonono
però zia Sonia ci può stare. Allora eccoci qui. Volevo parlarti di una scelta che
ho deciso di intraprendere, ovvero fare la mia prima volta con un gigolò, pagando
un escort praticamente, perché ormai ho
21 anni, non ho mai avuto né un fidanzato né
uno scopamicoo né un amico di letto, niente. Ho solo tenuto la mano a ragazzi e poi nulla di più. Siccome non
vorrei aspettare più questa magica prima volta che bisogna farla con la persona che ami
ho deciso di pagarlo invece almeno per avere un esperto e di avera una prima esperienza più bella possibile
invece che un'esperienza mediocre. Ah ok aspetta che continua
Scusa che sto volando io in questo momento. Vai vai vai. Voglio sentirti, preparati
Però non lo so perché uno non son tanto
economici e due
mi sembra una cosa abbastanza squallida.
E' una cosa che non ho mai detto a nessuno e
volevo sfogarmi un po'. E mi sembrava...
ma la gente poi mi giudicherà? A un vero
fidanzato come la spiegherò una cosa del genere?
C'è il catalogo perché sicuramente cioè
Lei ha fatto uno studio. "Sono anche un po'
costosi". Cioè ha fatto capire
Sembra quasi che deve mettere il
cartellino su una cosa che invece, voglio
dire, nasce proprio dal cuore dei
sentimenti. Non lo so eh. Certo se lo
sceglie, nel senso che alto, biondo, moro,
occhi azzurri, di un altro pianeta
Non lo so. Magari una bella bottiglia di prosecco e poi vai...Scusate ma io la penso così. Piuttosto che pensare
a perché non riesci a farlo con qualcuno o a
non avere con qualcuno la tua prima volta
chiediti piuttosto perché non riesci a
innamorarti...esatto...di qualcuno, non
riesci a trovare qualcuno che ti piace.
Forse non è il momento giusto ancora, non è
arrivata la persona giusta. Siamo tanti
su questo pianeta, sicuramente prima o
poi succede. Dopo che con Miguel hai
capito passato questa notte o con Pablo
il giorno dopo guarda che non è cambiato niente. Come
quando ti dicono "Dopo i 18 anni succede...fai 18 anni ed è tutto uguale". Mannaggia! Il gigolò a 21 anni
Però grazie grazie...scusa...nono. Grazie per la fiducia.
I tuoi segreti muoiono con noi. Certo
Hai una responsabilità anche nelle tue
risposte, non è facile. Ma infatti non hai capito
perché...io sono a posto. Sono bravo come Birillo? Bravissimo. Beh come spalla si, una bella spalla umana
A che età nella vita si capisce quello
che si farà in futuro, quello che si
vuole diventare da grande? Come si
capisce? Quando lo si capisce? Grazie, ciao
Io avevo una domanda che facevo
sempre ragazzi, "Che cosa vuoi fare da
grande?". Ah è vero! L'astronauta io ti avrei detto. Uno mi ha detto
"Il Papa", e lì è stata proprio...il Papa mi è piaciuto tanto. Un altro mi ha detto il contadino, dottore, infermiere
però insomma quando si è piccoli si hanno
queste idee così ben precise
Poi inevitabilmente crescendo, perché è
inevitabile che ti scontri con le
difficoltà no? E quindi tutto va
ridimensionato. Per questo senso proprio
di non sapere cosa fare da grandi. Se ci
pensi però è anche tanto dovuto
all'epoca in cui viviamo. Eh lo so l'incertezza la respiriamo anche noi che siamo più grandi
Banalmente un ragazzo che apre il
telefono, vede Instagram, vede
Facebook, dove tutti quanti cercano di
vendere la versione migliore di se
stessi, dove vanno avanti in quest'epoca
dove se tu non sfondi già da quando hai
15 anni. Immaginati tutte le star di
Disney che poi fanno queste carriere
A quel punto...non vali più niente...non vali più
niente! Quello diventa lo specchio di
quello che dovrebbe essere. Bravissima! La nostra è
un'età nella quale o è bianco o è nero
cioè quindi se tu fai un lavoretto, di
colpo sembra che per sempre ti rassegnerai
e la vita è finita. Buttatevi a fare qualcosa, perché almeno
incomincerete a capire cosa non volete
fare. Io volevo fare l'insegnate, volevo fare la maestra
ho cambiato, ho fatto la segretaria presso
un commercialista, non capivo niente di
numeri facevo dei disastri, però insomma l'ho
fatto. A la prova che ho fatto a
Super 3 era scrivere a macchina. Tutti
venivo di là perché sentivano "tic tic tic". Ero io che non
lo so quanti errori avevo fatto però
continuavo continuavo a scrivere, e quindi
sono entrata come segretaria. Poi da cosa è
nata cosa, insomma c'è stata un
cambiamento diverso però penso che
insomma uno deve anche crederci un
pochino no? E magari anche un lavoro
semplice però ti porta ad altre strade
Anche quando fai un lavoro che ti piace
tantissimo, non vivi di sola passione
Comunque arriverà quel giorno, quella
giornata no, quelle cose che dovrai
fare per cui in realtà ti devi
rimboccare le maniche e
devi comunque fare l'adulto e applicarti
Che saggio! No eh, bravo. Nono ma insieme, guarda sono un nuovo
androide. Cioè hai visto come sono
migliorati?...Giusto per farvi ridere
Ciao Gu, allora ti scrivo perché voglio un consiglio. Praticamente sono fidanzata con un ragazzo da circa
due anni. Un ragazzo con cui sto bellissimo ma
mi trovo in una sorta di limbo perché mi ha
scritto un'altra persona che reputo interessante
e non so quindi se mandare tutto a p*****e col mio attuale fidanzato
oppure se voler rimanere sola. Quindi non so che fare. Aiutami ti prego. Ti adoro grazie
Poche ore dopo. "Ok non serve più ci siamo lasciati
grazie lo stesso sei il migliore". Le scrivo
"Cuore cuore cuore, mi dispiace. Mi
risponde "Ci siamo rimessi insieme ma mi
vergognavo della mia instabilità emotiva"
Ha le idee molto chiare...Ok, è successo tutto adesso...Che altro aggiungere
Sul pezzo insomma ragazza, sul pezzo. Ho
appena letto il tuo post su Youtube dove
parli dell'ipotetica "Posta di Gu" e ne sono molto a favore perché credo che
tanti abbiano bisogno...Naturalmente io ho
detto Posta di Gu perché dovevo nascondere
Non ti voglio detronizzare Sonia ti
prego. Ho bisogno di un consiglio. Tu al contrario di
quello che dici sei molto saggio e
ispiri fiducia alle persone. Ho 26 anni
da un anno bellissimo, anche se
difficile, ho messo alla luce una bambina
che ho chiamato Isabel. L'ho messa alla luce da sola,
poiché suo padre ci ha abbandonate quando
io ero al quarto mese di gravidanza.
Ho tanta rabbia e tanto odio contro di lui
vorrei soltanto sputargli in faccia,
non vorrei fare altro. Ha cercato tutti i
pretesti, le scuse per lasciarmi e alla
fine ha fatto la cosa più drastica
ovvero tradirmi e poi andarsene.
Il consiglio che ti chiedo è se lui
dovesse tornare e pretendere di vedere
sua figlia, che oggi porta il mio cognome
che cosa dovrei fare? L'istinto mi dice "Caccialo! Rovesciagli
addosso tutta la rabbia che ti ha fatto",
però per mia figlia? Non devo essere
egoista e pensare a me stessa?
Se lei volesse conoscerlo, se lui avesse
la pretesa di vederla adesso, magari
quando avrà vent'anni chi lo sa non so
Cosa devo fare? Partiamo dal presupposto grazie, perché il
pensiero che tu possa veramente pensare
che noi siamo veramente degni di
ascoltare secondo me una cosa così a me
veramente riempie di...cioè mi fa veramente
molto piacere. Ti ringrazio, mi ha molto
toccato anche. Si sente quanto è addolorata
Si sente tutto. Non credo che avrà il bisogno forse di
vedere la bambina ma sicuramente
crescendo sua figlia si. E allora lì il
confronto è duro, perché vai a
giustificarti di fronte a un
comportamento del genere. Tanto comunque
i figli ti vengono a cercare no? Però lei
insomma brava. Ti stai facendo tanti
problemi di quello che potrà succedere
in futuro, di quello che potrà capitare.
Cioè io ti invito veramente a cercare di
affrontare dentro di te tutta questa
rabbia, questa tristezza e soprattutto di
trovare un nuovo equilibrio e non
smettere di guardarti intorno e non
pensare che una brutta persona
automaticamente sia uno stampino
per tante altre brutte persone. No certo. Ma qual'è la difficoltà a crescere? Ma come vi viene in mente?
Hai ragione. Perché ancora si sta bene casa. E' come se...la
difficoltà a crescere, ma è la vita, cioè c'è
anche questo, cioè i figli vanno amati
cresciuti. Non è soltanto il fatto di
metterli al mondo no? La paura della
paternità chi sa cosa uno possa
immaginare, mentre  in realtà invece è un mondo
fantastico da scoprire. Perdonami pure  la frase
Hai conosciuto un c******e! Cioè nel senso, purtroppo ci sta
Hai conosciuto un c******e, un codardo, un immaturo,
infantile. Ti auguro di trovare veramente
una persona vicino a te che possa amarti,
amare tua figlia
...come se fosse la propria. Si, come se fosse la propria ma soprattutto come merita. Non credo che un
essere così possa in questo momento
farlo, chi può sapere se un giorno verrà
col capo cosparso di cenere, come si dice,
fatti suoi!"
No sicuramente. Io mi sono lasciato con la mia ragazza dopo svariati anni di storia
La mia ragazza non era più innamorata di me, e sta con un altro. Da quando non sono più con lei, non
mi piaccio c***o. Mi guardo allo specchio e non mi piaccio
Sono disposto a farmi consigliare
anche da un labrador in calore
quindi perché non tu, almeno tu sei simpatico. Grazie Gu, ciao ciao...ah ciao ospite! Grazie, grazie
Beh quando uno soffre per amore uno
vorrebbe dirti "Guarda domani passa tutto"
Magari fosse così vero? Ci vuole il tempo,
purtroppo è un dolore che deve piano
piano andare via scemando quindi
importante è non chiudersi, non stare da
soli ma magari circondarsi dalle persone
che ci fanno star bene perché no
Anche dal labrador guarda. Anche da Netflix,
fino a che non ti addormenti. Esatto
Quindi bisogna andare avanti insomma, il
dolore piano piano si riduce. Lavora su te
stesso, prendi questo momento in cui non
ti piaci per fare cose al fine di
piacerti, che sia la palestra che sia
mangiare bene che sia interessarti di
qualcosa che sia dare amore ai tuoi amici per
riceverne. Esatto bravo. Ciao Gu, allora io ho un
grandissimo problema nelle relazioni con i miei
amici. Non riesco a mantenere un amicizia
per più di uno o due anni e succede sempre perché
a un certo punto vengo ignorata, comincio
a diventare diciamo il fanalino di coda
del gruppo, quella che se
anche manca non è un problema, anzi. Non capisco se sono un'amica cattiva io
o meno, anche perché non mi sembra di
esserlo dato che mi propongo sempre per
ascoltare, dare consigli. Sono sempre
quella che cerca di capire cosa hanno gli altri
e dare una mano. Spero che tu mi possa aiutare, grazie. Lei ascolta tutti, la domanda è chi ascolta te?
Esatto! Ti è venuta la stessa idea? Si, di fare il
contrario quello volevo dire. Incomincia a
...a chiedere...inizia a essere più attenta,
inizia a vedere quanto quelle persone
sono disposte a comportarsi come tu ti
comparti con loro e quindi non rimanerci per
...male...un'insicurezza e incomincia
a filtrare, perché non tutti sono
abituati alla gentilezza e non tutti forse
la meritano o la cercano. Gu quanti anni hai
veramente tu, dillo. Eh lo so, sono un androide te l'ho detto sono Birillo. I robot non
hanno un'età...Sentirlo dalla regina dei consigli è veramente un onore
Eh ma era molto più facile dare il consiglio a un bimbetto di otto anni
che alla ragazza dei 26. Stai scherzando?
E' difficile in maniera diversa. Eh ma io indirettamente lo davo...ai genitori...esatto! Non ero mai dalla parte del
piccolo perché era troppo semplice, però
qui è diverso. Quindi tu in realtà stavi dando dei
consigli a persone fatte e finite
coi figli e mi stai dicendo che questo è
difficile. Sono difficili in maniera diversa. Sei troppo...eh ok, i problemi di cuore...questa è umiltà
Io direi un secondo di prenderci una pausa
perché sono a pezzi
stiamo veramente morendo e anche in
quanto automa devo andare a ricaricare
le batterie. E io ho un'altra piccola urgenza. Ah si? Eh. Ok perfetto
Ci prendiamo una pausa lunga una settimana, ci vediamo quindi il prossimo giovedì sempre alle 14
con un altro video insieme a Sonia,
la seconda parte. Ok ciao ragazzi